I'm knocking it off I finished the Ted
Bundy tapes list oh yeah
so how'd they go I mean I wasn't much
more to learn other than that I didn't
realize he like represented himself in
yeah that was like a writer you study
he's in law school
yeah but that was like some I mean also
matt said that he would have gotten off
probably if he had a real lawyer like
the only reason why he got convicted is
because he he's a dumbass he represented
himself he fully he weirdly he fully
could have beat the case yeah because
the evidence against him was [ __ ]
weak mm-hmm he did oh man he like just
basically said I'm a serial killer and
one of the spoiler alert in one of the
court cases he goes in he cross examines
a witness and it was like the cop who
first arrived on scene okay and the
attorneys at the time like we're being
interviewed were they're like dude if
there is something you never do is its
cross-examine a witness because you're
exposing the gore of the scene and he
was like relishing in the murder and he
kept asking the same question like over
and over and like like he was like so
how did you find the victim when he
first entered the scene in as much
detail as you can recall so the cop like
goes in like the the one was late like
this her iowa's like that these
lacerations it appeared like this and
that and he's like what was the position
of her arms was the position of her body
to the point that they were like the
judges like you know you know objection
we're gonna have to pass on that he's
already answered that question and he
kept like wanting to like hear and wait
so did you do you learn about this
through his words in the documentary no
it's like it's there like that footage
of him doing that in the courtroom no
but I'm saying like okay I see yeah so
like the the isn't the documentary like
narrated by Noel sir no it's like it's
pieced together but it's kind of
centered around these tapes that where
he was interviewed and he kind of
you know whatever you like cops sort of
to the crimes he did okay but the the
dude was just like unraveling like he is
a [ __ ] psycho yeah the sickest thing
that means the judge after all that
looks at him and he goes you know I
think it's tragic you know I think I
think you're a smart young man and it's
just you know you just went down the
wrong path brother and I I hold nothing
against you and what yeah he says I hold
nothing against you I want you to know
that he was like I think he would have
made a fine lawyer and I'd be happy to
let you practice in front of me and I'm
like yo he murdered 30 [ __ ]
people and like tortured them too yeah
and then [ __ ] their dead bodies yeah
yeah how could you not hold that against
him that's not a wrong path thing wrong
a wrong path it's like you it's like you
got a credit card debt credit card debt
maybe you start messing with xanax a
little bit that's wrong it's not like oh
[ __ ] you know I murdered six people I
think I I'm ready to get my life back
together I went down a little bit of a
wrong path you know man I just last
weekend I put in I stabbed this guy at
the bus stop
yeah and I had this moment where I was
like who am i you know so whatever you
know I I just leave he bled out or
whatever but like I got home I smoked a
little bit I'm sorry that's not doing
this [ __ ] man then I had this yeah
well the moment of clarity came for me
when I was [ __ ] his dead body cuz I
looked down with his lifeless corpse
that I'm you know violating and I think
I think God
I'm trapped trapped again to himself
like a like a drunk girl until she wakes
up you know like you are a piece of [ __ ]
the decisions you made last night dude
oh my god dude you are not oh let me
tell you god I really have to stop going
out past 12:00 cuz I'm telling you it's
just I have no self-control it's crazy
so I go to this bar
and I see this guy in there and he's
sort of transient looking and like
already I'm like oh this is gonna be fun
so you know I walk up to him chatting
him up he's a nice guy holy [ __ ] I just
wanted to stab him right there but I
couldn't so you know I am you know we
get to talk and I buy him some liquor
and and you know I'm I said where you
from get this he's just a guy from
Oregon he just he's coming through here
he's just back back in America oh wow
really yeah jackpot his parents are dead
couldn't ask for anything more so I'm
like oh is that it we're in for a good
night so whatever I invite him back to
my place and I [ __ ] cut him into
thirty pieces and then as I'm like
putting him in a stew I'm like wait wait
metaphorically no no I hacked his [ __ ]
out of him after I like with your day
yeah no no I [ __ ] just cut him into
thirty pieces but this is like long
after like I choked him I [ __ ] him
while he was dead oh my god Titus ass
have ever been in any way that's besides
the point so I cut him up and I make
this [ __ ] stew out of his body and
I'm like Jesus I should become a chef at
least because it's so much easier than
this stuff and I'm really good at it but
God cleaning this stuff up every morning
afterward is just like ah it's such a
reminder that every every morning how
much like what's a weekend you know
definitely once a weekend thing okay you
know which is I can stop at any time you
know yeah but some do like oh my god
dude I took I just my brothers go back
from the bar last night woke up dude she
you know last night and then I went home
and then I went back to the murder scene
just to [ __ ] his body yeah but I
couldn't get away just I mean he had
such a nice ass and I couldn't get away
friends
yeah you went yeah yeah yeah you got it
man you got it you got it
9-1-1 hello hello help you got it man
it's all you that's all yeah no [ __ ]
socially insensitive just yeah
insensitive serial killer which they all
are anyways though yeah but they all
like glorifying gloat about it yeah you
feel like it's no big oh my god I can't
believe I killed talking about it like a
late soccer mom they just have that
energy about him oh my god oh my god I'm
so late anyway anyway okay so where do I
start where I start I definitely stabbed
him oh you need the whole thing yeah
yeah so sorry so sorry I was so late
getting over here anyway God okay it's
been a tough day traffic and you know
[ __ ] the dead guys body and I mean I
ran into some issues at the bank and
it's just been a tough day anyway so how
are ya this is your deposition oh right
right right right yeah yeah I tell you
I'm sorry sorry it has been a whirlwind
of a day I'm so sorry I tell you I I get
I get less time okay sure yeah yeah okay
so what knives that Cuisinart knives
that's what by the way Cuisinart loved
the brand great knives great knives
knives you'll keep for years you're
buying once and you'll Kim for years
that's why I love them knives and
pressure cookers surprisingly okay would
use that last Thanksgiving old oh no if
I were doing that anymore but so cook a
mean roast and you can cook a mean dead
guy yeah seriously it did a kneecap in
like 20 minutes it was crazy did he eat
them too or no I don't think he ate them
bad guy
necrophilia was definitely on his
[ __ ] agenda sick [ __ ] sick [ __ ] dude
yeah Ted Bonnie
[Music]
- I'm trying to flex not trying to flex
take your fish - no sir break that's not
a flex